welcome to this video playing Wolverine
yep frequently point I only have six
games against the sky it's hard to
believe feels like it on ok I've got a
bad bad score No so I have no particular
memory what we played really going to go
for my outline him ok it's going for
this d3 dashing out some quick moves
here with black ok yeah it's playing for
this regrouping with them queen of three
probably die before I will do something
in the center this is where this is
where this whole setup is aimed aimed at
let's say so can also take this chick on
g4 with the night now but just having
this space should be good just try to be
quick and I don't I don't really
remember the games against this guy
sometimes you can adjust your play a
little bit like you know ok is kind of
very quick or whatever then you try to
try to yeah try to act on that a little
bit try to trade his bishop on the truth
this looks like a good idea maybe maybe
seven bishops not not really the
greatest piece of em I think and after
takes Knight takes a to hang see to
hanks not quite sure what he's doing now
take your k goes back can still do this
right you will go to be three ok
I wonder if g6 is a move let's just push
this night back so that I don't have to
worry about it
ya know I remember Chad I played some
weird banco gambits against him yeah
yeah I'm remembering I'm remembering
this now ok so let's see quinta g5 might
be a move just cover and have six also
yeah okay cakes Queen takes oopsie five
might be on ok I'm pushing this back
just to make sure that nothing's
happening
gaining gaining some space night before
is the idea
yeah maybe I get some further another
piece that can go to c5 I really don't
know what night to g3 is about because
this is the worst possible square for
this night unless he I allow a sacrifice
which doesn't look likely okay so one
night a five-night c 5s idea it's just
kind of its kind of non centralizing
which is always something to take into
account
ok so I have chances to invade but
rather have this night on h1 just really
funky looking so how do i get to see to
doubling rooks will do the trick but f 1
i'm going to try to prevent f4 make it
more difficult at least to play yeah
it's doing that anyway so we're going to
take what now Queen a4 know like them
okay
that looks looks nice yes I just want to
get to see two now with the rook trying
to doubling Roxy to maybe has to play
Queen h2 this also aims at f5 at the
right moment okay
let's see Luke seat with also not
particularly bad but it's not
threatening much rook see one at least a
threatening to take that's the more
direct move don't really see what he's
doing now
yes and reply actually I'm winning know
now that's that's winning I've really
big material don't really see any any
reply if he goes on the second rank with
the King I'm Jake time checking him and
then take Roxy one no other nice to
achieve divide your exam nice to teach a
game i think i liked it i hope i think i
punished some of his self we had moose
um in the right way okay let's let's
pick up from here yeah okay compute that
wants to play at five but I don't want
to weaken my king position I just keep
them and keep the space yep I am a form
now on the queenside black is a nice
shape yeah this is this is the kind of
move that that I have problems with
understanding because what is this night
doing just looking at controlled squares
and you're not not going to to sacrifice
anywhere rather thought that you would
put it somewhere I don't know night h 2
f 3 or so on g3 it's doing nothing or
maybe if to e2 i don't know yeah and 8 a
3 year so it's debatable yeah you don't
want to cover this pawn all of the time
it's not easy to defend but here this is
definitely very nice image for pushing
this back the comp is even advocating
g5s poon yeah this is actually quite a
cool just completely stopping at form
and asking this night what are you going
to do if f3 i still can pile up here and
maybe have the Queen over here over here
yeah it's even stronger even stronger
than my move this is madness minus 1
though so not not particularly bad f3
was important to not allow him any
counter play f3
and now I'm completely invading I could
have checked him already well okay this
is good really no need to second guess
it was a was pretty decently played I
think yeah him he didn't really do much
about my queenside orphans and he spent
lots of time with some peace maneuvering
that didn't lead to much okay well
thanks for watching